wokester's rename a wizard's game where
jk rowling's tweets to blame for a fake
sport changing its name i speak of
quidditch the fictional sport made
popular by the harry potter series but
also my nickname when i garden topless
the game has been brought to real life
by pimply-faced college nerds with no
girlfriends before of course they become
comedians
but three organizations that manage
quidditch are changing the name to quad
ball quad ball in part to distance
themselves from harry potter creator jk
rowling and her so-called anti-trans
comments and partly to honor my amazing
quads
it is somewhat ironic though the people
erasing women added a ball to the name
quote the name quidditch and its
relationship to jk rowling carries a
stigma that no longer aligns with the
mission and values the values of the
international quidditch association
it is funny hopefully these young bucks
can also move past the stigma of still
being virgins
in the past rowling has taken issue with
phrases like people who menstruate
instead of the word women and defended
the concept of biological sex the
international quidditch association u.s
quidditch and major league quidditch
also ditched the old name because warner
brothers owns a trademark so it's a mix
of business and woke bs kind of like
nike but with no decent athletes or
slave labor
but
but before you get upset remember none
of this is real
like the notion that men can have babies
but the good news new sports are
invented all the time
oh hey charlie so me and the guys just
invented this awesome new sport and
we're starting a league no way can i
join definitely what's it called
office sucker punch
hey man you are a natural welcome to the
team
jim
um
let's point out you have been a large
financial supporter of the trans
community uh yes i have yes put many
trans women through college
i just wanted to ask that question
um do you think this is fair does this
make any sense well i mean as a big fan
of the sport um
i've been lobbying for a long time they
should change the name of it to this
game sucks
and quad ball sounds like a groin injury
you get playing quidditch
it's it's just more and more language
nonsense i mean they didn't change the
name baseball because ty cobb sharpened
the spikes and drove it into people yes
it's just stupid and it's a dumb game
and it should go away yes
applaud yes
dana
they won't let go of jk rowling and it's
just isn't it kind of amazing i mean
thank god she has few money because she
will never change
otherwise she would be i mean imagine
being her and saying wait i came up with
this stupid game in the first place yes
i'm the inventor you can't quit me i
quit you is what she is yeah they said
exactly i also am really um you know i
like to do research for the show oh this
is let me just everyone do not google
quad ball
okay
[Applause]
so what she really means is go google
quadbo right now
don't do it
because now i want to go google it
i definitely i'm looking at it during
the break i don't have to google it i
just go to the mirror
cat
cat do you have the athletic skills to
excel at quidditch
no i also i also wasn't allowed to read
or watch harry potter my mom said it was
like evil in devil's room
it's true
better be careful um
i just they're saying they want to
change the name because they want to
distance themselves from
harry potter i can't imagine a group of
people that want to distance themselves
from harry potter less
than people who play quidditch
like they're probably they they need to
they need to but they seem like people
who just simply cannot yeah i like who
is this for exactly i don't know
anything about the rules and i will
never learn i'm never this is something
i refuse to learn about but if they
think that jk rowling has like
disturbing attitudes about uh trans what
do they think about the people who
invented soccer do you think that
they're going to be pro trans or
football
people who invented any sport you know
probably not look and you said uh jk
rowling has fu money no she has f u f u
f u to the f you power money okay
that's how much money jk rowling has
hasn't she sold the most books in
history it's like it's some absurd
number that is like a billion it's it's
crazy
but people have to realize is that she's
the first woman who actually put herself
on the line to speak up for biological
sex and unlike um a lot of the other
ones when you saw the macy gray fiasco a
couple of weeks ago jk rowling has never
ever ever backed down and she never will
back down this is the hill that she is
dying on when so many people that she
made famous all the harry potter kids
distance themselves from her yes uh the
people that create this weird world out
of something that she created they're
distancing themselves from her so i
think that you know more power to her
for not backing down yeah but it helps
that fu to the fu power um squared money
yeah it helps and that's why it's that's
why this would be a good monologue i'm
gonna do it this week maybe tomorrow
that like it's weird how the the uh the
risk
ratio or whatever you call it has
flipped so it's older people that are
more willing to take risks and it's the
younger people that have turned into
these weird puritan puritans like you
know is that funny like john cleese you
just saw john cleese talking about
comedy all of these older comedians are
saying the same thing it's like what is
wrong yeah and where's the loyalty for
the people after all jk rowling even if
you don't agree with her i mean all
these people she made you star like i'm
hitching my wagon to you boss so
whatever you say goes you could never
lose me yeah i don't care what you stand
for what rallies you go to what you're
arrested for i'm team gutfeld all the
way up
yes
i
i have an ally
all right we gotta move on coming up
starbucks is sick of bums and their ilk
while peddling lattes with phony milk
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else